in today's morning rounds we're taking a
look at the changing face of cosmetic
injections nearly 16 million minimally
invasive cosmetic procedures took place
last year in this country and that
includes nearly seven-and-a-half million
Botox and other neurotoxin injections to
reduce wrinkles nobody likes wrinkles
and more than two and a half million
filler injections to shape the face
these enhancements traditionally require
visit to a doctor's office dr. Tara
nurullah shows us how new salons are
offering these injections in a more
casual setting but there are some
potential risks that we think you should
know about so Tara what are the drawback
of this salon well Gail these spas
called the dry bars of Botox focus on
anti-aging injectables they're designed
to be more convenient and less clinical
than a doctor's office and while it's
legal for non physicians like nurses to
administer these products professionals
say these procedures carry risks that
are more serious than a bad hair blowout
Caitlin Doyle is ready for her close-up
right centering above at her regular
Botox injection at alchemy 43 visited
before this year after the nationwide
chain offers only micro treatments
non-surgical procedures like Botox and
fillers in a casual setting similar to a
hair or nail salon I'm gonna be doing a
little bit of Botox around the crow's
feet I don't think that we should feel
like we're in a clinical cold
environment it's self-care and it should
almost be something enjoyable and fun
while social media inspires many to seek
out cosmetic procedures it's also filled
with customer reviews of various
companies showing the damage that can be
done
fortunately the vast majority of time in
any setting these are safe and they're
done properly but the public needs to
realize that this is medical care and
things can happen with medical care dr.
Alan Matarazzo is president of the
American Society of Plastic Surgeons
with injections you can lose skin you
can get gangrene you can get blindness
that require moments to treat by law
injectables must be ordered by doctors
and many states require facilities to
have medical directors but those doctors
aren't necessarily PLAs
surgeons or dermatologists and they
aren't always on-site and I just wanted
a little little left little tweaking
it's a risk that sherry who asked us not
to use her last name didn't know about
when she got Botox and filler last year
sherry has never been to alchemy 43 or
any other storefront Botox bar instead
she got her Botox and filler at a
private nurse practitioners office
within minutes she knew something was
wrong I'm looking in the mirror and I
think I'm turning purple the filler had
been injected into a blood vessel sherry
says the clinic's medical director was
40 minutes away and giving instructions
to the nurse practitioner on the phone
she's taking pictures and texting them
to him hours later the doctor arrived
with the medicine that could unblock
blood flow to the area around her nose
the only thing I remember him saying is
you're lucky you didn't lose your nose
which was quite alarming even after
oxygen therapy sherry was left with
damaged blood vessels skin discoloration
and severe headaches every morning I
have to look at myself and I see it and
it's also a constant reminder of what I
went through
so it's either not getting any blood
supply or it's having trouble perfusing
dr. rampion kassir treated sherry after
her filler complication injecting in the
face it could be dangerous because if
you get into any of these blood vessels
they can end in the eye it can end in
the forehead it can end in the nose well
even the most experienced doctor can hit
a blood vessel doctor kassir says it's
critical to have filler dissolving
medicine at arm's reach
we preloaded into these syringes so I
don't even have to stop and draw it out
you are getting a needle in your face
there is some risk attached to that and
we certainly don't take that lightly as
alchemy 43 founder Nikki Levy says her
staff is prepared for emergencies we've
been very diligent about training them
on that and we also keep all the
materials here that are needed in case
we did need to address something
immediately you have any questions give
us a call in between great so you just
had your procedure done how do you feel
I feel fantastic I cannot wait for the
next week to see the full results but it
was quick it was painless so it just
goes to show beauty is
pain procedures of these retail outlets
typically cost several hundred dollars
apiece they can be slightly less
expensive than going to a doctor's
office some even offer discounts for
frequent visits well we see the pros and
the cons sherry story I have to say
freaked me out just a little bit so what
question should people ask before they
go to a facilities like that yeah
there's several things to look at first
of all who's doing your injectables
what's their training how do they get
trained in a weekend course how many
injectables do you know that we should
just ask them what's your training you
you have to ask them there's actually no
real certifying body that that does this
for nurses or nurse practitioners or pas
and the law is really very
state-by-state in terms of oversight
which is really the second question so
who is looking over what you're doing is
there a medical director how far away
are they are they an anesthesiologist or
an OB guy nor are they a plastic surgeon
or dermatologist because sometimes it
can just be an MD do they have that
filler dissolving medicine at arm's
reach as they said and also who's going
to answer the phone after hours so if
you have a problem that night or the
next day or the day after what's gonna
happen if you can't reach somebody these
are really important things to us that
says that men said things can happen
with medical care dr. Mann you're so
number that goes over